hello my name is Maria and today I will
tell you about some really great tools
that we created to help people there on
quantum computing so earlier today you
heard a lot about quantum computing and
you have to admit that it's a very
exciting topic there is also this idea
of it being able to solve the problems
that are impossible to solve now so this
means that there are a lot of people
there who really want to learn quantum
computing what can we do to teach them
to help them learn the first step
towards teaching people is creating
materials that they can use to learn
themselves on their own so we all move
that learning with the teacher is
awesome
you can be guided you can have your
questions answered but not everybody has
the luxury of having accessed as a
mentor in fact I'm pretty sure that vast
majority of people learning quantum
computing these days are on their own so
we need to be able to help them and
there are a lot of materials on the
internet that cover quantum computing
I mean it's 2018 after all there are
books there are videos but a lot of
these materials have some disadvantages
first and if you're reading a book or
you watching some videos it's my
definition passive learning you consume
information but you're not very engaged
with it there are resources that over
active learning but there are very few
of them and really you cannot master a
concept or an algorithm until you have
actually tried to apply it to solve a
problem to implement all the reason and
it doesn't really matter if this is a
quantum algorithm or a classical that's
why the courses on classical algorithms
always have written assignments they
have labs they have ways to implement
things to make sure that you have
actually internalized them
second let's say you have found some
exercises to practice on
for example books books have exercises
but what if the book doesn't have the
answers or hints I have a very specific
book in mind it's the one which
everybody recommends to people who start
learning quantum computing it has lovely
exercise but it doesn't have answers so
if you have solved the exercise and you
want to check if you're correct or if
you're stuck on an exercise and you need
a hint
well congratulations you're stuck so
what we are trying to do we're trying to
remedy those issues we created a project
called quantum Carter's named after this
practice used in martial arts I heard
from people who actually tried martial
arts that it's a terrible name but I've
never done it myself so works for me
so the cutters are sets of programming
exercises on quantum computing that you
can do using a sharp each card offers a
set of tasks of increasing complexity on
one topic each task has to be solved by
writing some code so it's active
learning you try to do something
actively and the most important part is
that the car does have testing framework
which takes your solution runs it and
evaluate it to figure out whether it's
correct or not
so the cutters implement all the
principles of good learning it's
learning by doing they give you
immediate feedback and there is increase
in complexity of the tasks you attempt
but there are also answers for the tasks
in the code so if you're stuck you can
go to see the answers and figure out
what you have been doing wrong or in
what direction you have to be thinking
the coders project is only about a year
old
so far we have 17 Coty's on different
project on different topics they cover a
lot of topics that would usually be
covered in an introduction to quantum
computing materials started from the
very very basics like the gates that are
used in quantum computing like teaching
you to recognize the correct gate or the
situation to fairly advanced topics like
Grover's algorithm between I talked
earlier today about Grover's algorithm
and it's actually my favorite example of
what we can do to teach people because
it's one of the very famous algorithms
in quantum computing a lot of people
have heard something about it usually
it's something like all right it's this
algorithm that can speed up database
search that level of detail but once you
actually go in and try to implement it
and try to implement it to solve a
certain problem even a simple one that's
when you start to figure out how how is
it that it works what are the things
that nobody mentions and trust me there
are things that books don't mention and
kind of the more you play with it here
the more you start to understand that
maybe a database search is not the best
application for this algorithm the kata
are all open source and freely available
available for everybody to download to
learn themselves to teach other people
in fact they're open source so a lot of
them were contributed by people outside
of our team and they're available online
as Jupiter not books now it's time for
demo well I like to live dangerously
this is the Carta which teaches new to
solve problems with Grover's algorithm I
did mention that is my favorite right so
let's take a look at how this works okay
it doesn't minor technical malfunction
now it does
so I'm running this locally it's also
available online but I didn't want to
run the risk of dropping internet
connection or something exciting will
exist so it's a Jupiter notebook you see
there are some instructions in the
beginning on how to initialize the
carton basically it lots and packages
that we will need to evaluate your
solutions and the first part is writing
Oracle's for the problems that you're
trying to solve so what does a Grover
algorithm do basically it's given an
implementation of a function which takes
binary input and gives you binary output
0 or 1 indicating whether this input is
the solution to the problem you're
looking for or not and the goal of
Grover's algorithm is to find any input
that will produce the value of function
equal to 1 it's basically trying to
reverse-engineer the function without
knowing what it is so the most
interesting thing about it is actually
implementing this Oracle that it uses
because you cannot use a classical
implementation of the function to get
this speed up that Grover's algorithm
gives you you need to declare and to
describe the conditions on the input
which will give you the answer so it's
really looking for so boolean
satisfiability problems are actually an
excellent example of the problems that
can be solved using proper search
because they map to this binary input
binary output really really well
binary input is just the values of the
boolean variables that you assign to the
very two variables and the output is the
value of the function so the easiest
example of a set instance that you can
do is this one the and expression of two
variables so you see that the first task
gives you a very simple task
it describes the inputs to the
operations that you will implement it
tells you what the goal is what's the
transformation as it's done as it is
done by your code should be in some
tasks it describes the return if the
operation has a return but this one is a
transformation so there is no need and
since there is a code cell in which you
actually write your code it gives you
the signature of the operations that you
need to implement and here you can write
the code I have this I have seen this
task once or twice before so I should be
able to write some code for it and run
it by visiting the cell executing the
first cell takes a little bit of time
but after that it's much faster ok it
actually tells me that the code I wrote
is incorrect
purely for demonstration purposes I
assure you so this is actually a
compilation error it will also tell you
if your solution is can be compiled but
it's incorrect and this one is actually
fairly easy to resolve it's just a
missing semicolon and then we're on zest
so again
sustance success so yes i indeed know
how to solve the first task so arches is
the second task offers a slightly more
complicated task
it's an org formula which is very
similar to end but in quantum it it
takes a little more effort to solve I
could go on solving these tasks just
because we have a lot of time from
cutting the previous talk short but
really I wanted the conscious of lunch
coming up soon so let's just walk
through the tasks so you see the next
one is another example of the formula
then we get to more complicated formulas
in which you need to actually combine
some of the pieces you have implemented
earlier and use them as building blocks
and then fairly soon they get to the sad
problem itself it gives you definition
of what is a salt problem how it can be
represented then it explains to you how
this task gives you the input how it is
represented because representing such
problem is you need to have to have some
data structure which represents it and
then on and on and then you get a full
thought problem with arbitrary number of
clauses then the second part of the
carton he offers you to implement
Grover's algorithm using the Oracles
which you have done in the third section
so this is one of the major principles
of the Coty's the next tasks build on
the previous ones or they covers the
topic from slightly different angle but
usually in the end of the kata you need
to be able to put everything you have
learned together
and in the end you have to implement the
algorithm and see how see to make sure
that it works even if you don't know the
number of inputs to see the number of
solutions there's a formula okay does
anybody have any questions at this stage
because in the second part I will be
talking about something slightly
different
okay excellent
work me return to the presentation mode
so now that we looked at the tools that
people can use to learn quantum
computing of their own in the second
part of my talk I will tell you about
how we used the quantum Carter's and
other tools to teach students quantum
computing and I will also how you can
get access to source because I excellent
materials just in case you want to teach
somebody
so this winter we taught the course
introduction to quantum computing at
University of Washington
Martin will tell you more about it after
lunch it was a major effort by a lot of
people in the team and it was a very
interesting experience just you know to
give you something to look forward to
and meanwhile I'll give you an overview
of the materials we created for it that
we are happy to share with other
teachers so here is an overview of
course materials basically it was a ten
week long course so we had 17 lectures
and we have slides from those lectures
we had written assignments that come
with the solutions we had six
programming assignments which I will be
talking about in much more detail we
offered a big fan subset of quantum
Carter's as Webb's
so the material which students can use
to learn the actual programming
necessary to do programming assignments
before they continue to do programming
assignments and also there were final
projects which we offered that students
do in teams
so we need programming we need
programming projects razors and final
exams but again Martin will talk more
about it
I shouldn't steal his spotlight here is
a brief overview of what topics we
covered in the lectures you will see
that these are topics that any
introductory course on quantum computing
will have in fact this course had a lot
more information than some of the
courses will have so it was a ten week
course and repeated who we had actually
several universities already using these
materials for teaching their courses and
one of our partners took these materials
and they basically took a lot of these
materials which are more introductory
except for a transform I think which is
a bit more advanced and from these
sections they only took first algorithm
and they made a great course they didn't
feel short on materials then there are
written assignments they are tasks based
on theory and applications they don't
involve any programming so basically
it's a task which is given to you on
paper and you return a write-up of it
it's also manually graded fortunately I
was not involved in grading them there
are four written assignments they cover
different topics of the course we gave
approximately one assignment for two
weeks
and then there are programming
assignments that's what really made the
course stand out because hands-on
component is always very valuable and
it's always done in normal computer
science courses but in quantum computing
it's a bit harder to do to do it
so the loveliest piece about it is that
the tasks are automatically graded our
teaching assistants loved me for it
because I mean there are only so many
times you can look at Sharpe code for
Grover's algorithm to grade it and it's
not a lot of times so they are very
similar to cicadas I will show them a
bit later and the games they cover the
same material but they are designed to
accompany the written assignments for
example if you have a task about a
circuit like the one shown here it's
really easier to just do it on paper and
if you if you have a task for example
about drawing a circuit it's it's down
paper but if you want to do something a
different angle programming assignments
are excellent for that so how we did it
we taught the lectures to introduce the
theoretical material then we offer
Dakota or several on these topics for
people to practice and internalize the
topic and then we followed it with a
graded and programming assignment
now it's time for another demo I will
show you the programming assignments
themselves just to continues the trend i
started who is talking about Grover's
algorithm this is programming assignment
from week four in which we covered
Grover's algorithm we also happened to
cover Fourier transform on that week we
had basically a snowpocalypse and it was
a long week to cover so you can see the
structure of the project here it's very
similar to structure of the colors you
have the file with the tasks you have
the file with reference implementations
which you can see just to check yourself
how it is graded and you have testing
harnesses the file with the tasks it's
similar to what Bettina showed us
earlier and this is how the car does
look when they are in project mode as
opposed to notebook mode and this file
is the only ones that the students get
when they get the homework you see that
it has a little introduction telling you
what topics are covered and what Coty's
should be solved before attempting this
material and then we have the tasks and
again they look very similar to the
Coty's they give you the inputs to the
tasks the output or the goal of the task
in the signature and you have to write
the code here so basically how the
workflow looks like we give this file to
the students the students work on it
fill in the blank spaces and at the end
of the week and once the assignment is
due they send it back to the teaching
assistant
them's a teaching assistant takes this
file the students file substitute it
into the project build with it actually
I can pretend that I'm a very lazy
student and this is the file which I
submitted really should have put more
effort into it but you know other
commitments so this file builds and then
if you switch to test Explorer mode you
will see that it has the ten tests one
test per task and if you do run all
tests you will see that all ten of them
failed okay I guess I'm not getting a
good grade on this one so the grading
part can be automated even further
because you can do this quoting over
files and substituting them and running
the tests on them you can do all of this
from command line from a script which is
what our teaching assistants need so
basically the one thing you care about
is how many tests passed this is
basically the grayed out of ten one
things that we are considering
[Music]
improvements on well obviously a lot of
things can be improved like I'm I want
to do a refresher on the tasks I want to
do more tasks and maybe a little simpler
ones because we got a lot of feedback on
these materials basically since the
tasks are too hard which I understand I
can error on the heart on the side of
being too hard sometimes one being seen
in this whole set you notice that the
car does come with the tests if you are
trying to solve them you get your
feedback immediately and you don't need
to think about how to verify your code
when you have this
programming assignment you only given
the file with the tasks you're not given
the testing harness the reason why we're
doing this this way now is that the
testing harness uses the correct
solutions a lot of times there is no
other ways that you can test the
solution other than compare it with the
correct one and these solutions are all
in the open you can just look at this
file find your correct solution
we cannot really give out a graded
assignment which comes with solutions
built in this is not how it's supposed
to work so this is why we had to
withhold as a testing harness for now I
think we can do better than this and
package the testing harness so that it
doesn't expose the student to the
reference tasks but also doesn't require
them to write testing harness upfront
because writing testing harnesses is not
trivial and most students just cannot do
it in the very first week that they have
seen this whole quantum computing scene
yet I think this is it for the material
that I had for you so any questions
as there is a micro coming up
the implementation is hidden when in the
cut is in the notebook rather than in
the project because you said like
essentially the project which we are
seeing here is the same that we have in
book format like here it's essentially a
different front-end for the same thing
because that you have seen in the
assignment so I can show you the
repository where cicadas reside github
repository you have seen the links
previously and for example if you look
at the same Grover's algorithm there is
the same solution violent project file
and it has the reference implementation
file which has the answers so in the
notebook format they are hidden purely
by virtue of just not exposing people to
this file structure just because Jupiter
notebook you look at the notebook and
it's it doesn't show you the rest of the
files in that folder but if you go to
the repository you can get access to
these files so for programming
assignments we can do the same thing we
need to package those files tighter like
build them up in India well at least so
that the students can still like
disassemble the DLL and reconstruct what
was inside for it but honestly if they
do that they deserve that great thank
you any other questions
I guess this is it then thank you for
listening to me